all right well the big theme that we're
going to talk about today
it has to do with balance
which is a subject that's come up many
times in the history of this podcast the
idea of living a balanced life or
living your life in pursuit of balance
and i want to talk about this
in the context of what i'm grappling
with right now
as we mentioned prior to the break
i've been writing i've been on a writing
jack lately i'm i'm working on
putting together volume 2 of voicing
change
and what's interesting about this is
that this book is very much a team
effort i've got designers i've got
people who know how to do book layouts
i've got graphics people
i've got georgia who's helping me with
some of the writing on it
and and you know they've been doing this
for
months at this point so every two weeks
we do a zoom call it's an
update on where they're at and they're
progressing like very methodically and
gradually
through the manuscript and i have this
guilt and shame every time i get on one
of these zoom calls because i've done
nothing
you know and they're like rich you need
we need this this and this from you you
got to do it and i'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i just could not get off
my ass
and start working on this thing and greg
would be like just work on it like
an hour or two a day just chip away at
it and i'm like yeah yeah yeah like
intellectually rationally that makes
sense
but i just couldn't make that happen
[Music]
but now we have looming deadlines
and deadlines are very effective in you
know catalyzing
you to you know get on it
mainly out of fear but i've been
paralyzed to just
begin but i finally cracked the seal a
couple weeks ago
and what happens in my experience is
that when i crack that seal and i just
start
suddenly i become
not just invested in it but
but it becomes like all-consuming like
it starts to monopolize
my focus and the only thing i want to do
is work on it so
this obsession kicks in where i then
crowd out everything else in my life and
just go down the rabbit hole and i just
work on it for like 12 hours a day you
know and exhaust
myself and then i wake up at three in
the morning and start working you know
it's crazy
it's right it's not balanced right away
you get into that mode
or does it take a while well there's a
there's a little bit of a lead up mm-hmm
you know and then it and then it kicks
in and it's it's like addiction right
i've just become a full-blown addict
where it's like
the relief there's a relief in
sitting back down and being engaged with
it and there's also
this sense of impending greater relief
that you're nearing a certain finish
line and there's a discomfort with
not working more quickly towards that as
a book writer i'm sure you've
experienced this right
yes i uh i relate to this not with
basically any assignment i'm working on
the it's the hardest part is getting
getting yourself to actually
start you know i remember with one
breath i was terrified because i'd spent
the better part of a year researching
and i had all this
research now it was time to i had an
outline now it was time to actually do
it
and i was terrified that i couldn't do
it you know i had like two
and a half months to write a book did
you have a like a
an extended period of paralysis though
before you actually
yeah i think i think like i could have
started writing it
while i was still researching it but i
told myself you know no you got to do
the research first and then
um and you know then i didn't i couldn't
luckily in that situation i couldn't
afford to
have the paralysis so i've had extended
periods of paralysis
with the current book i'm writing with
my well deadlines will
will cure you of right supposed writer's
block
to indulge in there was no there was no
chance of paralysis for that so i i just
dove in but
but what you're talking about is the
pressure is on you and you feel the
pressure
and then as soon as you start especially
in a writing process i find
you get some ease right away yeah you
feel like okay
i can now see myself if i just do that
again
i can i can get to the end and then once
you're well it's like a locomotive right
you know the first part is so slow
right and then you hit a certain
inflection point where you're like okay
i i feel like i know what i'm doing i
wouldn't say downhill but you hit a
stride
yeah and you get the momentum and that
carries you and then yeah momentum is so
powerful it's such a self-perpetuating
energy source it's so difficult to
covet but once you have it i feel like
it's so important to protect it against
everything else because it's fleeting
like if the
if that momentum gets drained somehow i
just know all too well how difficult it
is to get back into that
state where you can allow the momentum
to propel you forward
yeah it takes it takes consistency to
get
back to the momentum because if you if
you're if you have it going then you
have to take a break
then it's going to take a couple days
for you to get back into the roof
so this process for me always
always uh connects me with like guilt
and shame
because i feel like why can't i just
work on it
responsibly an hour or two a day then i
would be in lockstep
with my team who has been doing that all
along rather than trying to play
catch-up which makes me feel even
guiltier
but i've learned julie's always like
it's because you love it this way you
love it don't complain you're not
allowed to complain about this because
you
always do this right like there's some
part of you
that likes it or
um gets something out of it right even
if it's an
unhealthy habit it's still doing
something
for me which is why i keep doing it the
procrastination creates pressure and the
pressure creates better work
yeah so the way i rationalize it is
this is how this is what i need to do to
do my best work like i can't just pop in
and out
because it's in hour six that things
really start to come together and it's
that
experience of immersion where you're
just
totally all in and the rest of the world
disappears
that you put yourself in the position
for that like extra
piece to come out i think there's
something to that i don't think it's a
hard and fast rule but i think it's
something to that like
if you're really under the gun that's
when and you're you're
living and breathing and there's no
separation certainly you can have some
great moments of inspiration but you can
also have them
on a walk in in the middle of that kind
of experience okay i'm gonna take a walk
i'm gonna go outside and catch my breath
and
then it comes to you so i don't i've a
long while ago i kind of stopped trying
to figure out what the perfect
conditions are for writing or what the
you know the best
place to do it or how to do it or this
process or that process
you just have to do it in whatever way
you can get to it
um the fact that this is your process
now is great and you know rob bell says
uh every project will demand maybe a
slightly different process
from him and i look at him yeah and this
is total projection
but it just appears that it flows
effortlessly like out of that guy
because he's such a constant font
right creative output and i have
you know this unhealthy thing which is
if it doesn't hurt then you didn't push
yourself hard enough and it could have
been better
which is at odds with this idea that
i've tried to embrace
but have been unable to master which is
what if it were easy right like what if
it what if it just flowed like what if
it were easy
what if you let go of that story that
revolves around the grind
and what comes out of the grind and you
just allowed yourself to be in a space
where it just it just comes because
you're in the allowing rather than
in the forcing and that's the mountain
that i've tried to climb and i'm
i'm still at the base of that mountain i
would say well i have had go ahead sorry
no no
please i also get accused of
interrupting you too much i think i
interrupt you constantly
i'm i i've interrupted people my entire
career
like at the beginning it was really bad
i listened to the interview tapes
and i'd cringe at myself it's gotten a
little better but i do it to you as well
but
all i was gonna suggest was that
uh if you look at sports or if you look
at
how you got better at a certain thing in
athletics
has it ever been through just easing up
no be and that's the lens that i use
because right you know my narrative is
everything that i've been able to
accomplish is a result of me
being willing to outgrind everybody else
and work harder right
it's not a talent thing it's a it's a
it's a grit thing
right and so that's my default but
i'm not so sure that that is the
healthiest and it's certainly not
the most sustainable because it's
exhausting right so i go
i do these mad sprints and then i'm
depleted
and then i need to recover right as
opposed to
what i would imagine or what i project
onto rob bell which is that he's just
consistently
you know creating all the time and i'm
not saying it's effortless for him but
he would appear to have a healthier
relationship with
his you know inner muse such that he's
not
like he doesn't hold himself out as
somebody who gets exhausted because he's
no i think it's easier to be prolific if
you're doing a little bit at a time
every year
like like the hemingway thing from 6am
to noon and then he's at the bar right
you know kind of thing
yeah i think ryan holiday does a good
job of that too like he talks a lot
about that like he's just
constructed his life so that these are
the hours that he does the thing
and you know he does it no matter what
it's a stephen pressfield approach to
the whole thing
right and i i really aspire
to master that i have a lot of other
moving pieces in my life at the same
time
when i wrote finding ultra it was
different that was the only thing that
was happening but now
there's a lot going on and so figuring
out how to squeeze that in
while these other things are still you
know on track has been the challenge for
me
but one thing that i have done is try to
be a little bit more gentle on myself
and rather than indulge in that
guilt or that shame like why can't i do
it that way why do i always set myself
up for this and why am i putting myself
in this position but to just kind of let
go of that
and say look for whatever reason
this is my predisposition this is how
i'm wired
and at least for right now i'm going to
embrace that aspect of me and let go
of trying to judge myself against some
imaginary standard of what a balanced
person's life
looks like and i think the reason
that i wanted to bring this up today
isn't to like talk about my personal
experience but as
an instructive kind of launch pad to
talk about
something i think is very common with a
lot of people which is this idea of
living a balanced life what does it mean
to
pursue a life of balance and is that
something that we should even aspire to
do
right what do you think i don't know
well i think
i think that that that sets people up
for failure and i think
most people have some version of what i
experience which is a sense that they
can't live up to that
they have this idea they look out into
the world and they see person x who
seems to be
excelling in their life in all
categories and they say
how can i you know be be a be a great
mom
and be uh you know professional at my
job and
make sure that there's food on the table
and also you know
go to the pta meetings and you know all
the stuff right like
and it sets up an unrealistic uh
set of parameters or expectations for
the average person
so my whole thing is letting go of that
and focusing not on how you can
be balanced on an everyday basis
and all the things that you're trying to
do better at
but rather focus on the thing that you
are doing in the moment
and be the best version of yourself that
you can in that moment
and understand that nobody can do
everything every single day
well so it's more like a toggle switch
of
being invested in what you're doing in
the moment and then switching gears to
the next thing like i can't you know
first of all multitasking is a misnomer
there's no such thing as multitasking
but we still have this idea that we can
like switch gears
and go back and forth from other things
and some people are better at that than
others and i've learned that i'm not
good at that
i'm good at doing one thing well
and then slowly moving to the next thing
and focusing on doing that thing well
but i can't
toggle switch back and forth within
a single day my wife is very good at
that greganzalone is very good at that
right it's a different set of skills so
it's about
understanding what your strengths are
and what your weaknesses are and then
trying to orient your life
around addressing those
rather than guilting yourself into why
you can't do it like somebody else is
doing it
maybe that's your balance your balance
is
i do one thing at a time really well and
that's how you feel the most balance
like what does it even mean to be
balanced does it mean that you can do
x y and z at this incredibly high level
because that doesn't seem balanced to me
that just seems like
a great aptitude for work well how are
we measuring balance right
and what is the time frame and one of
the things i'm always talking about is
expanding
you're expanding the window upon which
you're evaluating your ability to
to live a balanced life if you're
looking at on it if you're looking at it
through the microscope of of of
you know your daily routine most people
are going to fall short of that i fail
miserably at that but if you look at it
over a long continuum
then you're giving yourself larger
bandwidth
to say okay i'm doing this one thing now
but what are the other things in my life
that are important that are not getting
as much attention as they should
when i finish this then i got to make
sure that those things are
in order and in the background hum you
know the other things that are important
need a little bit of
daily nourishment but perhaps aren't
going to be
getting your full attention but then
understanding like okay when that's done
then i need to
reconfigure my life to focus on these
other things so over the course of
several months or a year then it looks
like it's in balance
right but when you look at it like if
you look at my life on a day-to-day
basis it's completely out of balance so
brad stollberg the other week we talked
about steve magnus and we used his
kind of quote and something that he had
written as a topic
uh for for discussion um
steve steve's writing partners brad
stollberg who's also been on the podcast
new york times contributor um
outside magazine contributor have you
ever met brad i have not you would like
him he's great
but he's written extensively about this
subject and
one of the things that that that he said
is
that a lot of people swallow this
cultural message of balanced balance
balance
then they struggle to find it and they
get down on themselves because they
can't do it everything every single day
they think i'm going to wake up i'm
going to have some family time i'm going
to work i'm going to go to work from 9
to 5. i'm going to come home
more family time cook dinner watch tv
show go to sleep but that's only one way
to think
about balance and this is where i really
resonate with brad he says try thinking
about balance being over a long
continuum this gives you permission
to go all in for periods of time that
way you can experience flow
and still have a balanced life it's just
that the balance might be over five
or ten years not every single day and a
corollary to that is this idea that
rather than striving for balance
striving for self-awareness instead
the ability to know your core values and
evaluate the trade-offs inherent in
pursuing them
and i love that it's also the subject of
a new york times piece that he wrote
called maybe we all need a little less
balance
someone's quoted and that someone is
quoted in there i know i you know i
pulled that
article up i'd forgotten that he
referenced me in it um
it's not why i'm bringing it up but i
just think it's a great read
for helping people recalibrate how you
think about these things and despite the
fact that i've been
you know droning on and on about this
for a long time i found myself in the
process of
working on this book project to go right
back to that
level of self-judgment that's
counterproductive rather than just
saying this is what i'm doing now
for whatever reason here i am back again
doing this thing i said i wasn't going
to do again which is
you know going down the rabbit hole and
and blocking out everything else and
not doing it in a you know a more
managerial kind of way but
this is the way that i do it and that's
okay yeah
i mean i'm totally with that i think
like
this idea of balance this idea of
finding your passion and following your
passion or finding the one these are all
somewhat cultural myths
to some extent and to me we are here on
earth to find ourselves
first and that requires some
self-reliance and independence but it
also requires some
mutual dependence and interconnection
and it's all
it's all this like equation that we're
trying to find the answer to
i mean equanimity is kind of like a
corollary to enlightenment right when
you find like when
when the person the bodhisattvas and
meditation to achieve equanimity is to
achieve enlightenment well like what
does equanimity mean right
it means no one achieves it in their
day-to-day life right you know and so
yes in terms of how do you get the best
conditions for you to feel
comfortable in your skin comfortable in
your life having your family do well
having your career do well all that that
balance sheet
it seem to me we're talking like life's
balance sheet
um and and it's
like that's a moving those graphs are
like jumping up and down and i think
when it comes to writing two things come
to mind number one is
you just have to get the work done and
you have to live with those
you know critics like the hecklers and
from the muppet show
in your head that are gonna constantly
be jabbering not to
date myself but constantly jabbering in
your head about what you're doing and
the way you're doing it
the two old guys the two old guys up
there tune out the boomers in your head
and and you just have to you just have
to you know
surrender to the process and the process
is going to be uncomfortable a lot of
the time
the idea of flow state and athletics i
think you can find it
and you can find it in writing i have
found it in writing where i'm like wow
this is amazing and i feel like all
i feel the flow just because
the the the experience feels good though
doesn't mean the work will turn out
right like to be good yeah that's the
illusion right yeah i think oh it's
going good it's going right
but then no back to the drawing board
and sometimes pick it up another day and
look at it
right and sometimes you bleed the words
every word
costs like a pint of flesh or something
and
then you go back to read it you're like
wow that was really good you hated the
day
it felt miserable um when that happens
to me though that just affirms that
story that
pain is the driver of quality
right you know which is not a healthy no
so i think
whether you're feeling doubt about a
project or feeling good about the
project the key is to turn
tune both those things out to get the
project done
that's my only experience of it and it's
something that i struggle with every day
like
last week i was the one complaining
about my writing
process it's not comfortable it's not
it's not necessarily
always a fun job yeah yeah and you're
doing it now with a newborn like you
have
a new set of challenging complicated
variables that you didn't have to deal
with before
it's true it's true but at the same time
i have more time to actually every day
go and do a thing
because i haven't been on the road right
and so
um but that hasn't led to prolific being
super prolific right but well i like
that idea that brad talks about with
self-awareness and i think it's related
to the piece you were speaking about
with respect to equanimity yeah you know
like
be the most present and self-aware that
you possibly can
when you're in the midst of doing the
one thing that you're doing
you know and that idea of equanimity
made me think of that i don't know who
said it that quote
that um nature is never in a hurry but
everything always gets done
and i think about that and i'm like i'm
always in a hurry right most of the
stuff i'm trying to do doesn't get done
but i don't know but looking at your
lives
but like that's that's the story i'm
like why didn't i do that i didn't get
anything done today you know
it's that's that's the self-defeating
um looping you know thought pattern
that's going on in my mind
that if i don't make the time to
meditate and
you know practice those mindfulness
things that are so annoying like that
gets the best of me
you definitely feel it like when when i
don't do that
those little pieces like them you know
i'm not really having time to meditate
too much but i have like an affirmation
with
zuma every morning after yoga if i get
to yoga if i can do it
so it's like you know you're right if
you
if you can start off and hit hit the
first things that you know are good for
you
then maybe you have a chance you're
taking out an
insurance policy on having a better day
yeah you know
um but this idea of balance though like
you're saying um
i think the whole inspiration for you
right i mean correct me if i'm wrong
is it's okay to to tackle this book that
way
because you know it might just be the
way
you are now rich roll this version of
yourself that's your nature right now
doesn't mean that will be your nature
forever it's definitely my nature
and the idea is for me i think to
be in self-acceptance of that but also
not do it in a self-destructive
addictive way like to get the best out
of
my ability to immerse myself in a
project and be focused
without the kind of downside aspects of
it that i think
are you know a relic of you know history
of
of alcoholism right that i think comes
into play i think about that when i'm
out riding my bike up pch and i see the
surfers out there or somebody out
swimming and i'm like i should be
swimming
or i should be surfing and i can
guarantee you if i was surfing
i'd see a cyclist and i'd be like i
really should be on my bike right now
you know what i mean like there's all
it's not a grass is greener thing it's
more like
wanting to do everything simultaneously
all the time and
and just being present for what you're
doing in the moment
it's like living at the intersection of
yolo and fomo
yeah you don't want to be there how do
those two
intersect in the venn diagram that'll be
next week well the more yolo
the less fomo right right but yeah what
you're saying is you have fomo for the
yolo you're not doing yeah that's true
because there's yeah there's always
something else that you're missing out
on there's multiple yo-yos
yeah in the extended yolo universe
yes there's there's there's infinite
fomos right yes yes exactly
but when you think of yolo you don't
think of hunching over a computer and
typing a book although
when you think of fomo you can
definitely god right that book well i
could be out training and saying
oh my god like i really need to be
getting on this
like i have anxiety because the book is
not going to write itself right you know
that kind of thing
and these years don't come back to you
they do not
they do not did we accomplish anything
productive for the listeners
when talking about well you know what i
think i think the listeners gonna be
like wow
rich is just as [ __ ] up as we are
there's hope there's hope
[Music]
you